what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to top
21
tick tock men keeping their wives and
girlfriends
in line here's how i start my husband's
day off um
the return of men before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell
and also follow my instagram guys it's
just pearly things
with a z and the link is in the
description i'm trying to hit 10 000
followers on instagram so each and every
one of you helps me hit that goal
um also subscribe please off right i
start by writing down three reasons why
i love him
then i fill up his water bottle to make
sure he's hydrated
next i start on his green protein
smoothie to make sure he has good
nutrients for the day can't forget about
the aloe vera juice for his gut health
the most important part to have good
energy would be iced coffee with some
almond milk and agave
once i'm finished with all of that i
start on the cleaning process because
of course who likes to wake up to a
dirty kitchen
before i wake him i put on some
christian music and then i
gently wake him up with a little hand
squeeze
okay this is what i mean ladies you reap
what you sell
so if you're putting that kind of effort
into a relationship i bet it's a good
one
i don't know i don't think
[Music]
if you had 24 hours with me and i
couldn't say no
what would we do all right here's the
paint
here's your roller that hallway's not
going to paint itself okay
[Laughter]
damn who is this fun girl
i am so glad you popped up on my screen
oh my goodness you got a
booty look at you
when my girlfriend has a dream i cheated
why does the sound go away
damn that's happened to me before i was
so mad
and then i woke up and realized it was a
dream
so i match with this very fine female
named brook and in her bio
it says she's a scorpio and then she
wants to be roasted
so you know what i did so because i'm a
gentleman
i ask for permission that she really
wants to be roasted and she told me
to give me her best so i gave her my
best
so i tell her you're the type of girl
that puts her zodiac sign in her bio to
seem relatable and down to earth
but you really don't believe in it and
you want people to roast you because
you're not here to actually get to know
someone
you're just on this app for the dopamine
that you get every time you get a new
match
and you look for reassurance from an app
that you're attractive
when you've probably never been treated
right because you're always looking for
the next big thing
and actually you don't trust guys at all
based on how you've been treated in the
past so you decide to make tinder
as a joke just to see you're capable of
matching with
and she unmatched me so i think i did i
think i won
oh my god sorry oh my god that was funny
there's this super cute guy at the gym
bro what the heck
[Music]
hey excuse me yeah um i just want to say
i think you're really cute and i was
wondering if i could get your snapchat
no all right excuse me
i'm good trust me i don't know you just
kind of kind of busted looking uh i go
for
more like got it got it
damn that was mean i understand you guys
are saying like don't
don't simp whatever but there's a point
where it's too far and it's not nice
[Music]
okay this is how you know
that he's gonna take her back i
guarantee he does i'll tell you why
because a real guy that like it is
i'm done with this girl i don't ever
want to see her again
he leaves without arguing because he saw
what he needed to see he's
done he'll go break up with her whatever
but
this emotional reaction wouldn't be
there unless
he's saying you hurt me and i still i'm
gonna stay
guarantee he stays
that's what makes you beautiful
hey babe you want to play call of duty
with me i thought you were just doing
the dishes in the kitchen right now
really that wasn't me my twin sister's
here to help us clean
did you say hi uh yeah i said hi
ah ah that's weird so my boyfriend has
had a really long
crazy busy week so i wanted to surprise
him and do something nice
so i got all dolled up curled my hair i
put
makeup on since he's pretty much seen me
only looking like a bum and quarantine
i wanted to put on a cute little outfit
so i put this cute dress on
i went to texas roadhouse to pick up
some
food he loves ribs so i got him some
ribs
and then i went to his house before he
got home because he was at a hockey game
i lit a candle to light the mood
and just showed me some of the food here
i also grabbed a bottle of wine
i put some music on fawzi's my favorite
here's the little setup so we got ribs
mashed potatoes
some rolls salad and of course
bacon cheese fries because they are the
best
i hope you enjoyed it
take your man out on dates oh
[Music]
oh that's so cute
that's so cute
why is there no sound on some of these
but damn that girl is a good ass cook
wow that looks so good
now that we're married shouldn't you
sell your cards and spend a little bit
more time with me
are you crazy you're starting to sound
like my ex-wife
what you never told me you were married
before me i wasn't
for my husband's lunch today i'm going
to start by placing in a piece of
parchment paper
for this section i'm going to be making
some mini bell peppers
with cream cheese and of course the
everything but the bagel seasoning
next i'm going to pack in some roasted
peanuts
along with these new kodak granola bars
lastly i'm going to slice up some
cucumber and carrots
and then pack in some ranch for dipping
and now that this is ready to go
moving on to the main portion where i'm
going to be making some
tuna fish sandwiches i keep the tuna
salad pretty simple by doing mayo
mustard some seasonings
and sweet relish and then for the extra
kicker i do some sriracha
first i lay down some lettuce then the
tuna salad mixture and then my tomatoes
lastly i'm going to cut okay this is for
the ladies that can't cook
even that you don't even have to know
how to cook to make that sandwiches in
half so they fit into the box
better and i always like to toast my
bread to keep it from going soggy by
lunchtime
now that the lunch is ready to go i'm
packing it all away and of course
including a note to tell my husband that
i love him
that's so cute what's up tick tock so i
just want to know
am i the only man out there that their
woman don't chat them
when they say hey babe i'm going hunting
explain what kind of wife you are in one
video
let's go
that's so funny
so i came home today to this
my wife said i needed a beer and stocked
my fridge
full of beer and ice
sometimes when you find that keeper you
just keep them
and say thank you
happy early birthday what the [ __ ] is
that happy early birthday
what do you mean happy birthday happy
early birthday okay
this is so cute oh cash it's done
cheers happy birthday yeah [ __ ] way
happy birthday um
happy birthday i can't even there's a
second surprise
i see it soon he's got the keys
i can't even darren delivered it to me
today
i bought we bought it on tuesday holy
i've been in cahoots with your dad for
several weeks now
i had to like hide the text messages
because he and i met up there so he
could test drive it
and be with me oh this is so cute
so this comment is very
i love this couple i love them
they give such good advice
ignorant and inconsiderate
i was 24 she was 23.
had nothing built something lost
everything and recovered together
she has been with me through thick and
thin
she has even sold her wedding ring at
one point to put food on the table
she has been through welfare with me
through food stamps with me i
only wish that every male
could have a life partner like i did
i promise if you go back and look at our
videos
you'll agree with me i love that couple
i love that couple mostly because they
really
promote like young women and men
actually saving themselves till they're
married and i think that's such a good
message especially for young women
especially for young women but
okay that was such a feel-good tick-tock
that was so fun
um that's so much more light-hearted
than the stuff i usually see in the
manosphere
um okay guys you already know what i'm
gonna tell you go follow my instagram
just pearly things
with a z do not forget to subscribe to
the channel bring that notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next
time